a couple of orioles tonight will wear
number 21 in honor of the great roberto
clementi including trey mancini this
year's orioles roberto clemente award
nominee for means there are the numbers
of course the no-hitter back in early
may
judge on a foul tip is down swinging a
change up for strike three
there's nestor cortez jr on the mound
tonight making his 11th start of the
year good era 2.70
swing i'm going to miss
here we go angles and arm slots two outs
here on the bottom of the first the 2-2
straight three
hayes gets punched out with a generous
call
john carlos wearing number 21 on roberto
clemente day around major league
baseball
an apple drill
that's the way you get giancarlo who's
standing out
[Applause]
so here is sanchez at 210 21 homer's 51
rbi
a one
hit in the air deep center field mullins
heading back he's on the track he's at
the wall he jumps up does he take it
away
cedric mullins you better believe it
grand
larceny in center field
cedric mullins electrifies the crowd
with an unbelievable catch
here's the o2
swing and a miss
one away
[Applause]
apple lasered by aureus a gap shot to
left center field this will
split stanton and gardner for a what out
double ramon urias
[Applause]
right down the middle
maria is still at second and valencia
takes ball four
so second straight night with a walk for
pat and the orioles have two on two out
for kelvin gutierrez two out pitch his
strike three fastball now you could say
john widen he's swinging it
line drive a base hit over a leaping try
of vallejka mullins gets it in saw a
lead-off single for gardiner now here is
gio michelle at 2 58 11 homer's 41 rbo's
high fly
deep left field going back mckenna
turning looking sia a two-run home run
for urshela and it's two nothing yankees
well the sheller came into last night's
game four for his last 36 and last night
he went two for three so maybe he's
starting to come around here just at the
right time down the stretch
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
line drive
and it's through
the shift on the left side for base hit
now stanton will stop at second a base
hit for torres so he's walked and got a
single
a 3-1 fastball
and a 3-2 fastball popped up
should be an infield fly in effect here
it is for an automatic out number two
and he could not hold up so hayes down
on strikes and let's strike out number
six
strike three santander down looking
strikeout number seven
[Applause]
and the pitch is cut on him as he is
something isn't he that court face
tonight eight strikeouts he just struck
out the side again
eight strikeouts in four innings
there you go see you
away away away and then maybe a generous
inside corner trying to get through five
and it looks like he will
malaika
judge runs well he just got him in time
yankees don't have a challenge left so
that play will stand
there's one like that
there's a rocket for pat he's been on
base twice tonight the 3-2
swing and a miss
strikeout number nine for cortes
[Applause]
that's lined and caught by a diving
ochela for the final out of the fifth
inning he took a hit away from austin
wins
3-2
and he walked
connor green comes on hard throwing
righty i mean he can get the ball you
know 95-97
green sets so too
and rings up torres 97 with a sinker
from connor green he ends the top of the
sixth
one two
struck him out swinging that's a new
career high what do you think of that
again so ten strikeouts from a guy who
doesn't throw hard in six innings
and the pitch
swing and a miss one off speed with the
slider strikeout number eleven eleven
strikeouts for nesta cortez and a 17
ounce recording
austin hayes left center field and
absolutely
walloped
into the oreo bullpen
for number 19.
and the o's are resoundingly on the
scoreboard and a blast from hayes
that's a good defensive play by
gutierrez
well it's a double you know it's a
double and all of a sudden you know nice
pitch kind of because of this play
and that one is lined into right center
field it's a base hit mullins cuts it
off in the gap going for two as gardner
the throw
not in time it's a double for gardner
here in the seventh oh one
swing and a drive under right field
playable for austin hazy comes in makes
the catch and connor green points back
to his right fielder and ends the top of
the seventh with the yankees left
stranded ryan mckenna takes ball forward
well one pitch in the game stop all
right so here's chad green 13 home runs
that's that's the number that jumps out
at you in 74 innings mckenna the base
runner at first pitch slider did he go
he did
every pitch a slider
2-1 pitch
wins laces it into right field moving
over as judge can't get there it's down
as winds collects a single lining one
out in front of his former college
teammate
and that one hit shortly and knocked
down they throw to first now flowing to
second austin wins is in there so torres
knocked down the hot shot and decided to
take the out at first why did he throw
the second i'm not quite sure
and that one gets away from sanchez and
wins will go to third
one out runner third did he go
yes he did
he could not hold up on a curveball way
out of the strike zone so he's who's
got a new bat today who's very excited
about that before the game it's like
christmas he's already homered with it
green goes back there hayes drills it to
left gallow back at the ball it is gone
pick me out a winner austin
two home runs with a new piece of lumber
the orioles have taken the lead
well there's number 20.
pretty timely orioles three ounce away
from a comeback one of the yankees tyler
wells will try to get him
[Applause]
and he walked him
so the leadoff
batter is on for the yankees that's luke
voight
and here comes tyler wade
that one is lined into center field it
is a base hit
so the yankees have runners on first and
second and nobody out here in the night
the 1-1
runner goes slow to third he's in there
wade steals third base and going in
behind him is is at second wade's at
third torres at second yankees down by
one we're in the ninth inning and brett
gardner at the play starting to rain at
camden yards
popped up is that going to find grass
yes it does it's a base hit one run
scores here comes torres he'll score
a bloop two-run single for brett gardner
oh did the yankees need that and they
lead four to three
and that's booted by morton and
everybody is safe
up the middle
long throw
mount castle kept his foot on the bag
what a play so the fact that chapman had
to come into a game yesterday where the
yankees had a 5-1 lead while now you're
putting in a position to do something
that hasn't done in three years pitching
three straight games
swing and he missed got him
the throw to first put out 2-3 and the
yankees win 4-3 and in a season that's
been a rollercoaster ride this game is a
microcosm of the season up down
up again and they get a much needed
victory four to three over the orioles
they've won three in a row